the Apple watch is the most personal
device we've ever created the I think it
takes us into a whole different area we
had a we had an intense team working on
those for three years and so we explored
many different things and as the product
came to fruition it became not only the
timepiece that you would expect but a
device that can do many different things
include really a whole new way of
communicating and connecting with people
and also it has a health and fitness
component that we think has you know it
could could it really be provided with
health care there is a wide open field
to make some really profound
contributions and so our entry into this
is we announced healthkit in June health
kit allows if you want if you wish on
your phone you can begin to take all of
the data that's in all of your health
apps and aggregate those you might elect
just to use that yourself you might
elect to interact with your doctor on
them and so now the sudden we've also
got a device that gathers certain
Fitness data about you and yet so this
is yet another way to begin to build a
comprehensive view of your life which
should empower you to take care of
yourself over time and when you need
help it empowers you to take certain
data to your doctor to get help from
them
all all while guarding your privacy so
that nobody's getting the data if you
don't want them to have the data
nobody's sharing the data if you don't
want them to share the data and no we're
not keeping it iPhone 6 it's not the
first iPhone but it's the biggest
advancement ever an iPhone history and
so we think that the upgrade cycle here
and the number of people that will
switch from from other smartphones it
will be enormous our system is much more
secure than the traditional credit card
system and we kept the thing that people
liked which is they do
love their card and we said we don't
want any of this data so we're not doing
what other companies are doing we don't
want to know what you're buying we don't
want to know where you're buying it we
don't want to collect all this stuff on
Charlie I don't want to know where where
you're spending your nights and so we
firewall all the stuff where we don't
keep it it's done on our servers and and
so we kept what's great and fixed what
wasn't